hi I'm Jillian Bell from the new movie
Britney runs the marathon and this is
your weekend ticket
thanks Jillian new in theaters this
weekend Jillian Bell and Britney runs a
marathon
Hustler's and the Goldfinch what will
you see this is your weekend ticket this
week's top ticket Britney runs a
marathon 50,000 people from around the
world are racing today I want to run the
New York City Marathon I think that is
such a good idea I'm really good at
making profiles it's not that bad I'm
just gonna give you mine okay do you
know how to spell herpes
[Music]
whole life the world told me I was lazy
because the way I looked was trying to
turn my life around everything's gonna
be fine people help doors for making how
old doors for you you change your life
was never about your wait was about you
taking responsibility for yourself it
had its world premiere at Sundance
earlier this year but this weekend it
strides under the big screen for its
wide release in this heartwarming comedy
from Amazon Studios Jillian Bell plays
the party loving exercise hating Britney
who after getting some hard-hitting info
from her doctor decides to turn over a
new leaf get healthy and train for the
New York City Marathon this story is
based on the experiences of a real-life
Britney who is a very good friend of
director and writer Paul downs collazo
as of this recording Britney runs a
marathon is at 90% fresh on the tomato
meter and certified fresh so that's more
than enough reason to run to the theater
to check it out this movie is for you if
you like feel good inspirational
comedies you're a fan of the comedic wit
of Jillian or movies about marathons
take your breath away when I was a kid
with animals I was close these Wall
Street guys I stole from everybody
hard-working people lost everything and
not one of these douche bags went to
jail
the game is rigged and it does not
reward people who play by the rules
it's like robbing a bank except you get
the keys are you in these are my
coworkers
what if somebody calls the cops and says
what clubs and help hope you brought
enough ones to buy a movie ticket cuz
the celebrity-packed hustlers comes out
this weekend said around 2008 that's
based on a true story story follows a
group of strippers fed up with wealthy
men and decide to hustle them out of
their money using tricks wits and some
sisterly teamwork like I said there's an
all-star cast here with Constance Wu and
Jennifer Lopez as the leads and also
cardi B keke palmer Julia Stiles Lilly
Reinhardt Liz oh and even uh sure is
stuffed in there somewhere
this movie is for you if you're a fan of
any of the talented cast you love a good
based on a true story movie or you
already know what song you'd pole dance
to I danced to fair use copyright free
music
[Music]
when I lost her I lost sight of any
landmark that might have led me
someplace happier
[Music]
you're a boy are you the boy whose
mother was killed
[Music]
next up the Goldfinch comes out this
weekend after a tragic and mysterious
explosion in an art museum kills his
mother a young boy's life is sent
spiraling over several years he has
tested learns about himself and what's
important in life
all while clinging to his one piece of
hope the painting of the Goldfinch he
stole from the rubble that fateful day
the movie is based on the Pulitzer Prize
winning novel of the same name written
by Donna Tartt with judges saying the
story it stimulates the mind and touches
the heart which is what a lot of the fan
mail says about this show this movie is
for you if you're looking for a powerful
and touching movie you love another
great ensemble cast it stars like Finn
Wolfe heart Nicole Kidman and Sarah
Paulson or you like stealing priceless
works of art that is your weekend ticket
what will you see and check back next
week for ad astra starring Brad Pitt and
a bunch of space pirates
[Music]